piensa en lo siguiente estás por
regresar a clases después de vacaciones
y están preparando todo parece gran día
se espera la asistencia de
aproximadamente 500 84 estudiantes y en
tu escuela hay 20 salones cada uno con
el mismo número de bancas imaginando que
no faltará nadie crees que todos tendrán
una banca como podemos saberlo no es tan
difícil existen varias maneras de
averiguar por ejemplo podríamos ir
contando de uno en uno uno dos tres
cuatro cinco pero no así sería muy
tardado son 20 salones tendríamos que
contar muchas veces
otra manera puede ser contar una por una
las bancas de un salón y el resultado
multiplicarlo por el número de salones
que tiene la escuela en este caso 20
pero todavía es tardado así que una
manera más rápida es sumar únicamente
cuántas bancas hay en cada fila y el
número de filas que hay en un salón
quieres ver cómo ayúdame a contar
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 bancas por fila ahora
el número de filas 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 y listo
multipliquemos el número de bancas por
el número de filas 5 por 6 igual a 30 lo
único que nos queda hacer es multiplicar
este 30 el cual es el total de bancas en
un salón por el total de salones de la
escuela es decir 20 entonces 30 por 20
igual a 600 perfecto sabemos que en tu
escuela hay bancas para 600 estudiantes
por lo que si asisten
84 estudiantes no habrá ningún problema
hasta sobran lugares antes de que sea el
gran día
los directivos desean arreglar la
escuela y pintar los salones cada bote
de pintura cuesta 70 pesos y alcanza
para pintar dos salones entonces cuántos
botes de pintura se tienen que comprar
para pintar todos los salones y cuánto
se gastarán en total hagamos una tabla
aquí tenemos que un bote alcanza para
dos salones y cuesta setenta pesos con
dos botes pintamos cuatro salones y
gastamos 140 pesos con tres botes
pintamos seis salones y gastamos 210
pesos si seguimos aumentando botes
aumentan los salones que podemos pintar
pero también se incrementa el costo para
poder pintar los 20 salones tendríamos
que ir sumando un bote y 70 pesos por
cada dos salones para llegar más rápido
al resultado podemos multiplicar por 10
porque 2 por 10 es igual a 20
y necesitamos diez veces más pintura
entonces el número de botes se
incrementa también a 10 1 por 10 igual a
10 y el costo también 70 por 10 igual a
700 hay cuatro colores diferentes rosa
azul verde y lila los salones se
pintarán de un color por dentro y de
otro por fuera lo cual significa que no
se pueden repetir los colores en el
mismo salón cuantas combinaciones de
colores habrá para saberlo escribimos
los cuatro posibles colores para las
partes desde adentro rosa azul verde y
lila junto a cada uno vamos a poner los
posibles colores para las paredes de
afuera pero quitamos de la lista el
color que ya usamos por ejemplo si ya
escribimos rosa entonces solo pondremos
azul verde y lila ahora hay que hacer lo
mismo con los colores que nos faltan
contando cada posibilidad vemos que son
12 combinaciones diferentes si no
quisiéramos escribir todas las
posibilidades
solo tenemos que contar el número de
opciones de la primera decisión que en
este caso son las paredes de adentro y
multiplicarlo por el número de opciones
de la segunda que en este caso son las
paredes de afuera 4 x 3 igualados como
te diste cuenta al escribir las
combinaciones de pintura podemos
imaginar cómo se verían los salones pero
si sólo queremos el total de
posibilidades lo más rápido es hacer una
multiplicación